to save our democracy we have to make
the u.s government
faster more efficient and more effective
and we can do that by expanding the
power of the executive branch
to use fast-track authority to approve
all types of legislation
believes stanford political scientist
terry mo
moe who's the author of president
populism and the crisis of democracy
wants congress to have the power to
approve or deny
laws through an up or down vote but not
to add amendments or
filibuster their passage the cato
institute's gene healing
says that non-libertarians of all
political persuasions
suffer from a dangerous devotion to the
boundless nature of presidential
responsibility
healy who's the author of the cult of
the presidency
says that instead of giving the
executive branch more legislative
authority
presidential powers must be brought back
to their constitutional limits
do u.s presidents need a fast track or
should their power be
sharply curtailed terry mo and gene
healey
went head to head on this issue in a
recent virtual soho forum debate
moderated by soho forum director gene
epstein
tonight's resolution reads
to make the federal government more
effective
presidents should be given fast track
authority
to propose bills for all types of
legislation
that congress must approve or deny
by majority vote and without change
uh terry mo will be defending the
resolution
cato institute vp gene healey will be
opposing the resolution and now uh
again speaking on behalf of the
resolution professor
terry mo you have 15 minutes take it
away terry
uh look let me start out with the
following
simple statement we in the united states
have a government that just doesn't work
it's chronically ineffective and
incapable of dealing with the complex
hugely consequential problems of modern
times
for example for decades it's done a very
bad job of dealing with the horribly
disruptive effects
of globalization and technological
change which have led
to job losses to a hollowing out of
manufacturing
to a decimation of many local
communities especially rural communities
to the opioid crisis and to great
financial loss
insecurity and stress among tens of
millions of americans
we also have an unworkable immigration
system that has caused
widespread cultural and economic concern
and then there are
serious problems of health care
pollution a crumbling infrastructure
and much more including needless to say
the pandemic well our government has
been highly ineffective
at dealing with all of these
the result is not only that our society
and our people
are worse off which in itself needless
to say is hugely important
it's also that ineffective government is
literally
dangerous to our democracy because it
leads to alienation
disaffection and anger with our system
of government
as the rise of populism and donald trump
well demonstrates
this anti-system rage
leads to a rejection of our democratic
institutions and it threatens
to bring our democracy down
the fact is a democratic government that
can't respond to the needs of its
citizens
and respond effectively cannot survive
this is true everywhere throughout the
world and it's true for the united
states we're not special
in that regard so why is american
government so
ineffective
obviously many factors are at work
polarization
most notably but the fundamentals of
this problem can be traced back to the
constitution
itself i know this sounds like sacrilege
we all love the constitution
and it's truly a watershed achievement
in the entire history of human
self-governance
but we need to keep in mind that the
framers wrote the constitution more than
230 years ago
and while the bill of rights is timeless
the specific architecture of government
laid out
in the rest of the constitution is a
different matter
the framers designed a government for
their times
for a simple isolated agrarian society
of less than four million people
most of them farmers government was not
expected to do much then
and the framers purposely designed a
government
that couldn't do much they designed a
government
that separated authority across the
branches
they filled it with checks and balances
and veto points
that made coherent policy action
exceedingly difficult
to the point that it led often to
outright dysfunction especially in
modern times
the framers put congress right at the
center
of lawmaking and congress is right at
the center
of the dysfunction as a decision maker
congress
is just inexcusably bad and utterly
incapable of taking effective action on
behalf of the nation
most observers point the finger at
polarization and they say that
you know if we could just move to a more
moderate bipartisan
brand of politics congress could get
back
to the good old days when it did a fine
job of making public policy
and all would be good but all would not
be good
because the good old days were actually
not good
the brute fact is with some exceptions
like the civil rights act and the voting
rights
and some others congress has never
throughout our long history been capable
of crafting
effective policy responses to the
nation's problems
for documentation take a look at peter
schuck's book
why government fails so often which
provides an encyclopedic source
of well-documented evidence on our
government's persistent
history of ineffective policies
polarization has made a bad situation
worse in recent times but it is not the
underlying cause of congress's core
inadequacies
those inadequacies are baked into the
institution
congress is an ineffective policymaker
because it's wired to be that way by the
constitution
whose design ensures that legislators
are electorally tied to their districts
and states and highly responsive to the
constituencies and special interests
that get them re-elected
congress is not wired to solve national
problems in the national interest
it's wired to allow hundreds of
parochial legislators
to promote their own political welfare
through special interest politics
and that's what they do because of
polarization and because of all the veto
points and collective action problems
congress has often been just gridlocked
unable to act at all
but when congress has been able to act
its law making process has typically led
to cobbled together
policy concoctions that are crafted on
purely political grounds
to get disparate legislators
representing very different special and
local interests
on board not to provide coherent
intellectually well-justified policies
that effectively address the nation's
problems
the point for them is to patch together
something
anything with enough votes to pass
not to solve problems in the best
possible way
so look no further than u.s tax policy
which is not a policy at all
but a grotesque conglomeration of
thousands of special interest
favors and loopholes or witness the ways
in which insurance companies hospitals
drug companies and other vested
interests
profoundly shaped the affordable care
act
turning it into something that no one
would have designed that way
if they wanted a cost-efficient
well-working system
this approach to governments may have
been fine for the late 1700s
but that era is long gone and it's not
coming back
what we need is a government that is up
to the enormous challenges thrust upon
it by the modern world
what we have is a government designed
for a primitive world nothing like our
own
it shouldn't come as a shock that this
antiquated government
which was not designed for our world is
simply
ill-equipped to deal with it and does a
bad job
so what can we do well the u.s
is clearly not going to shift to some
other form of government or even embrace
radical changes
of the government that we have that
being so
a practical strategy is to pursue
smaller changes
that leave our system pretty much as it
is but promise
big payoffs for effective government so
here's one approach
that we think makes good sense with
congress the prime source of dysfunction
we should move congress and all its
pathologies
from the very center of the legislative
process and we should extend much
a much more central role to presidents
why presidents because their wiring is
very different from congresses
and actually propels them to be the
champions of effective government
historically trump aside this has been
true
regardless of whether presidents are
liberals or conservatives democrats or
republicans
seekers of big government or small
government unlike most
legislators excuse me presidents think
in national terms
about national problems and their
overriding concern
for their historical legacies for being
great
drives them to seek durable solutions to
pressing national problems
needless to say presidents aren't always
successful or right
and conservative presidents would seek
very different policy solutions
than liberal presidents but all
presidents aspire to be the nation's
problem solvers in chief
and if control of legislation can be
shifted partly
not wholly partly in their direction and
away from congress
the prospects for effective government
will be much improved a simple way to do
this
is through legislation or a
constitutional amendment if that were
possible
although legislation could do it that
grants president
fast track authority in the law making
process
the u.s has more than 45 years
of positive experience with fast track
authority and international trade we've
been doing it for decades
going all the way back to the trade act
of 1974
that same model would simply be applied
to all legislation
or barring that to as many important
types of issues
as possible including nominations
under fast track presidents would craft
policy proposals
which are likely to be far more coherent
well integrated intellectually well
justified and effective
than anything congress would typically
come up with
congress would then be required to vote
up or down
on those policy proposals without
changing them
and it would be required to vote within
a specified period of time say 90 days
and on a majoritarian basis so
there could be no delays there could be
no filibusters
and no amendments filling the
legislation with new earmarks loopholes
and
special interest provisions even with
fast track in place though
congress would still retain the
authority to pass laws on its own if it
wanted to
and presidents would still retain the
authority to veto those laws
all right so critics might say that fast
track
would make the president a dictator well
it wouldn't
both houses of congress would still need
to give their separate consent
before any proposal becomes law policy
would be a three-way decision
not a presidential decision and the
court system and separation of powers
would remain
intact along with the bill of rights
moreover to ensure passage of his policy
proposals
presidents would have strong incentives
to get lots of input from members of
congress
while working up a bill and to engage in
whatever compromises are needed in order
to gain sufficient support
in addition congress could send the
proposals out to its committees
to get opinion and advice so again
presidents would hardly be a dictator i
should add that
in giving presidents new agenda powers
so these are
fast track only deals with legislation
it adds nothing to the president's
unilateral powers
which are the powers that we really need
to fear
indeed a big reason presidents have
favored executive orders and other
unilateral actions
is that with congress such a disaster
the legislative process is all but
unavailable for solving problems
under fast track five minutes five
minutes
presidents would seek out legislation
more in unilateral action
less and this would be a big plus for
our democracy
consider immigration for example
president bush submitted immigration
reforms to congress in 2005 and 2006
and president obama submitted another in
2013.
all of these bills had majority support
in congress the votes were clearly
there yet the first two lost on
filibusters in the senate
and the third failed because speaker
john boehner refused to even bring it up
for a vote
in the house the result no reform
a festering immigration problem and
executive actions by obama
on daca and other shifts in policies
that have caused much
consternation on the political rights
with fast track
the nation would have passed a
comprehensive bipartisan immigration law
many years ago
and there would have been less reason or
no reason
for obama to take executive action now
consider a very different example
suppose fast track were applied as we
think it should be
to all nominations obviously we need
these key positions to be
filled and quickly in government
agencies and in the courts
if our government is to do its work and
do it well
for decades however we've had a very
serious problem with presidential
nominations being endlessly delayed in
the senate and many are never even acted
upon
under fast track every nomination would
receive a majority rule vote by the
senate
up or down within 90 days there would be
no delays and no strategy of delay
the most reasonable expectation is the
great majority of these
nominations would just go through and
the courts and agencies
would be more quickly and fully staffed
and better able to do their jobs
so look there's much more to say of
course but here's the bottom line
in the united states the most
fundamental challenge we face
is that our government is profoundly
ineffective when problems don't get
solved
our society suffers from poor health
care
from rising sea levels from decaying
communities from crumbling
infrastructure
from out of control immigration and more
deeply affecting our quality of life but
that's not all
because when a democratic government
can't meet the needs of its people the
people become
alienated angry and anti-system as tens
of millions of americans are and have
been
for some years now their political power
is very real
and it threatens to bring our democracy
down this is not an academic matter we
need to do something
we need to make our government more
effective so that it can meet the needs
of its people
this doesn't require i should emphasize
a turn to big bureaucratic top-down
government
some progressives of course may choose
exactly that path
but conservatives can pursue effective
government by embracing policy
approaches that
through well-crafted governmental
designs harness the power of markets and
incentives to address the nation's most
pressing problems
carbon taxes for example to deal with
pollution
and climate change or market-based
solutions to provide affordable
healthcare
or rebuild rural communities whatever
the approach
we all have a stake in creating a
government that works
and then saving our democracy fast track
is one step in the right direction
it's a small familiar well-tested
non-threatening reform
that stands to have major payoffs it's
the mouse that roars
it would help to streamline a grossly
unworkable
legislative process and giving us a
government that
through law making not unilateral action
lawmaking
can deal more effectively with the
modern world and do a better job meeting
the needs of our citizens
if we don't take action to give
americans a better government
one minute one minute we're headed for a
train wreck
our democracy really is on the line
we do need to do something and fast
track
is a safe reasonable reform that
deserves our support
thank you thank you terry mo uh
and uh now taking uh the negative
on that resolution seventeen and a half
and a half minutes for you
gene healey uh take it away gene healey
okay thank you uh thanks my fellow gene
and thanks to all of you for tuning in
tonight
uh st patrick's day isn't what it used
to be and now that we're in the era of
social distancing uh but hopefully this
will be more nutritious than guzzling
green beer and you'll probably feel
better in the morning
i have to admit it is difficult for me
uh to imagine gazing out at the
hellscape of american politics
and saying to myself you know what this
country needs
a good it's a good dose of presidential
empowerment
uh hey after all the the
what we already called the most powerful
office in the world
has become dramatically more powerful in
recent decades
you know you look at the dragnet secret
surveillance programs global drone
warfare
and the pen and phone governance of the
bush obama years
and then you look at the new weapons
that donald trump has added to the
presidential arsenal uh like the ability
to use national emergency declarations
to do an end run around congress in a
budget fight
or the notion that you can order up
drone strikes on senior government
figures
of countries that we're not legally at
war with
the whole experience has been exhausting
and frequently terrifying uh what with
the president threatening war crimes
over twitter
and even on one occasion getting into
this weird freudian spat with kim
jong-un
over the size of his uh
well well it went like this quote i
too have a nuclear button but it is a
much
bigger and more powerful one than kim's
and my button works
all in all uh the trump years really
should have served as
a sort of a scared straight program
for well-meaning progressives who get
dewey-eyed about the promise of
presidential activism but it's like the
the chain gang warden says to paul
newman in cool hand luke
some men you just can't reach
uh professor mo tells us in his book
that it's important not to be
fixated on trump and the fear of
presidential power
he laments that the trump presidency has
actually scared many people
into thinking that the presidency needs
to be straightjacketed
which is an interesting choice of
metaphor given
the multiple times over the past four
years when we had
had to genuinely wonder whether we'd
handed over the machinery of federal law
enforcement in the nuclear codes
to a nut case still he says
if we bind potus down too much we'll
miss out on
the enormous promise that presidents can
offer as
champions of effective government and
the
proposed constitutional amendment it's a
in the book it's offered as a
constitutional amendment
uh perhaps some parts of it could be
done legislatively but
in both relic and the newer book they
talk about an article 5 convention
uh in order to get this done uh
the fast-track proposal is supposed to
help realize this uh
promise of the presidency uh
under it as he told you the president
writes his preferred bill
he gets a fast-tracked vote on that bill
and congressman uh can either rubber
stamp it or is
essentially veto it they don't get to
get their grubby little
thumb prints all over it
well in the interests of a lively debate
i really ought to be telling you that
this
i'm going to call it the moe amendment
is a doomsday device
that if activated will lay waste to our
republican form of government
uh it will all be left to scrabble
across the post-apocalyptic wasteland
uh you know searching for bullets and
toilet paper
but i'm not going to do that uh because
i really don't think that it wouldn't be
honest
uh the fact is that the proposal
doesn't absolutely scare the hell out of
me in every respect
i think what he just
said about it doesn't make the president
a dictator i think that's
largely accurate um so i i don't want to
paint
a darker picture than i have to i just
think it's a lousy idea
uh i can imagine circumstances in which
it's potentially quite dangerous
uh i think that in the best case it
rests on a sunny almost panglossian
a picture of presidential motivations
and i think that in the unlikely event
of its
implementation it would probably make
some of the problems
the he talks about partisan animosity
and tribalism
a good deal worse uh let's start with uh
where i can picture it going very raw
uh in chapter four of the latest book
um the the authors uh tell us that one
of the problems
one of the problems that it will help
ameliorate
uh is the irresponsible way that we
tend to drift into war these days uh if
the mo
amendment was in mo howell amendment if
you like was in force
then when the president wants to take
military action he can put his preferred
war authorization
in front of congress and force them to
stand to be counted
i think the good thing if congress was
forced to stay stand to be counted in
military matters far more often but most
of you are probably
familiar with the 2001 authorization for
the use of military force
or aumf that congress passed three days
after 9 11.
it gave the president the power to quote
use
all necessary and appropriate force
against those nations organizations or
persons
he determines planned authorized
committee or rated the terrorist attacks
that
occurred on september 11 2001. in other
words
go get the guys who did okay who did
uh 911 and anyone connected with them
three presidents in a row have stretched
that law into an
all-purpose justification for uh two
decades of low-level war in at least
half a dozen countries at any given time
and that's entirely congress's fault
according to
to mo and howell uh they write that the
language could not have been broader
well of course it could and it would
have if this amendment had been in place
here for example is some broader
language the president
is authorized to use military force to
deter
and preempt any future acts of terrorism
or
aggression against the united states
that's the language the bush the bush
administration
put on the table in negotiations with
congress right after 9 11
and talk about a blank check uh
preempt any future acts of aggression
this draft aumf that the bush team put
together
would have been a license for any future
president to unleash
fire and fury against north korea iran
or
basically any country that the president
decides
is looking at us funny but
if president bush had had the power
three days after 9 11 to force an up or
down vote on that language
do you really think that congress would
have voted it down with ground zero
still smoldering i don't
perhaps i'm concentrating too much on
the fear side of the equation but
there's also the
uh the promised side of the equation the
promise of presidential power
uh that idea is uh as professor mo
just uh unveiled to you it's rooted in
the the theory that the presidents and
congress critters are
wired differently thanks to the nature
of their respective offices the
president is
elected by the whole country means he
has to take a larger view be more public
spirited
look at the national interest as a whole
congressman basically
just want to bring home the bacon uh
on top of that presidents are he says
are
obsessed with their legacies which is
true uh they play to the ages they want
future generations to love them
uh and uh the part that i quibble with
is the idea that solving big national
problems
is quote their ticket to historical
adulation the way in which
they become that that and the reason
that they
routinely aspire to be problems the
nation's
problem solvers in chief they alone can
fix it
i think this is a bit of a character or
more than a bit
there's of course a wide body of
evidence showing that
like uh any swamp dwelling congress
critter presidents
tend to play pork barrel politics with
federal aid
they tend to direct it where it helps
them politically to swing states
and areas where they're partisan bases
concentrated
stafford act in the area of disaster
relief gives them a great deal of
authority
to do that so does it shock you to hear
that
disaster declarations spike in election
years and the battleground states
tend to get a lot more love probably not
um
would it scandalize you to to learn that
uh
presidents uh well before donald trump
uh used their unilateral powers over
trade to deliver
protectionist payoffs to swing state
industries
a good example is in the run-up to the
2004
election when george w bush hiked steel
tariffs screwing consumers nationwide
in order to give himself a boost in
states like ohio
and west virginia and it worked
so i i this uh
vast dichotomy between the parochialism
of congressmen and the
public spiritedness of presidents i
think is exaggerated
and as for this idea that uh solving
big genuine national problems is the
surefire
ticket to the esteem of historians uh
i have to borrow a joe bidenism come on
man
uh you know who is a real problem solver
in chief
jimmy carter and don't laugh
uh jimmy carter bit the bullet on
inflation
putting paul volcker in a at the fed he
let a wave of transportation
deregulation that made air travel
accessible to average americans and
made shipping cheaper faster enabled
just
in time inventory when you think about
these
pampered yuppies really have jimmy
jimmy carter to thank every time ups
drops off a pelleted bike or a pandemic
care package with sourdough starter but
do they thank him no of course not all
anyone
all americans can remember about the
carter presidency
is the misery index the hostage crisis
and that stupid cardigan sweater
jimmy doesn't get any historical
adulation either
for having been a good problem solver uh
the scholars who who rank the
president's
uh make him one of history's losers he's
a bottom half of the class
number 26 on average just ahead of
richard nixon
behind uh the so-called great presidents
like woodrow wilson who took us into an
unnecessary war
and uh mounted one of the worst civil
liberties crackdowns in u.s history
and james k polk uh who according to the
most recent c-span
presidential historian survey quote
ranks highly for his crisis
leadership uh which is one way of
the one way that you could describe
jenny up a war with mexico to steal
california
five minutes five minutes oh god i gotta
speed up then
um maybe jimmy carter should have
started a war
uh uh there uh it turns out to be a
uh uh in a regression analysis published
by david henderson
uh fairly strong correlation between
combat deaths under
u.s presidents and their historical
ranking
um none of what you learn about uh how
legacies are graded
uh is really going to incentivize uh
president to uh say get out ahead of the
threat of antibiotic resistance
or stand up a good asteroid defense
uh moreover the the the fast track the
track amendment is supposed to be a fire
break against the
medicine rise of populism uh we've got
as he told you a paralyzed government
overburdened with veto
veto points and uh it's this
ineffectiveness that gave rise to
uh donald trump in the first place is it
or does this smack a little bit of what
the psychologists call projection
it's not as if the 21st century has been
one long woeful tale of government
paralysis
uh we have a number of examples where
congress and the president
got together to do get the big things
done in accordance
with the president's vision uh the wars
in iraq
afghanistan the patriot act the
department of homeland security
uh after the financial collapse at the
end of that decade
uh stimulus package in the tarp bailout
plan
you'll notice that a lot of these big
ticket items feature heavily and
populous complaints
uh before the tea party drifted trump
word it got started as a populist
backlash against
bank bailouts uh with the exception of
immigration policy for the most part
actual populists aren't complaining that
elites sit there paralyzed while
national crises worsen they're
mad about what those morons did
it is also a little strange that uh to
to want to cool populist tempers
with a uh proposal modeled on the fast
track
process that gave us nafta and the wto
um like professor mo i happen to think
globalization has been on balance an
enormous boom but nationalist
conservatives loathe these fast track uh
trade agreements
and blame them for uh screwing the
american worker and
causing deaths of despair professor moe
says they're
at least partly right finally in the
unlikely event that
uh we had an article 5 convention which
we've never done in our history
and this amendment emerged from the
process and got ratified my strong
suspicion
is it would make the problem of red blue
tribalism
even worse one of the reasons the
presidency has been one of our biggest
fault lines of polarization is the fact
that the president increasingly has
power to shape
reshape vast swaths of american life
shape what our health insurance covers
what sports your kids can play
whether or not you're on the hook for
your student loans uh he has the power
to launch a trade war from his couch or
stumble into a shooting war in the
middle east you can
bet when the stakes are that high we're
gonna be we're gonna fight about it
bitterly
the mull amendment with its new agenda
setting powers for the president
raises the stakes even higher it makes
the presidency
an even bigger prize in a zero-sum
winner-take-all
partisan death match and if what we're
worried about
is the rise of populist demagogues we
should be heading in the opposite
direction
working to limit the damage that they
can do
when they take office reigning in
emergency powers war
powers trade authorities uh pen in the
phone
uh what we should be aiming at one
minute
is making the president safe from
populism and safe for democracy
none of that is easy to do but none of
it requires a constitutional amendment
and none of it presents the risks
entailed in professor
mo's proposal just say no to his
amendment
thank you thank you gene uh terry i
guess you don't mind it being called the
mo amendment
and uh terry terry mo you've got
uh we're keeping to the uh to the uh to
the length and uh schedule indeed
uh you have uh five minutes uh for
rebuttal
uh take it away terry well
um from my standpoint it's as though
gene just took a giant plate of linguine
and threw it against the wall
you know i mean to see what would stick
um
there wasn't uh from my standpoint in
the coherent
logically linear kind of argument being
made here there were just a bunch of
different
uh points being made that weren't
entirely connected to one another
so dealing with that kind of menolage
is not so easy
um so let me just make a couple of
points here
um one is that
uh it's important to think about both
the promise and the fear
of presidential leadership and
presidential power
and the fact is that presidents have
great promise
in promoting effective government
because we have a government that
doesn't work
it's all divided up it's all fragmented
and congress at the center is filled
with 535 people running in different
directions and
and responding to different interests
thing is a mess it's an institutional
travesty
and so we need a president to provide
guidance and leadership
and um it's our only hope for effective
government
so the idea that okay trump was
president
trump was scary
you know uh acting unilaterally
undermining
um uh the rule of law attacking our
democratic institutions
uh and much worse for four years
and so people hear well we should give
presidents this additional power or
authority and
uh fast track people hear that and they
go are you kidding
you know what we have to do is we the
lesson of the the trump years is tie
presidents up and nuts
that's what we have to do okay you tie
presidents up and nuts
and then our government will be even
less efficient
right we need an effective government
when we can't get it if we tie
presidents up
in knots okay so um
uh we have to then recognize that
there's two sides of this the other side
is the fear side we have
reason to fear presidential power but
what we can do is constrain
presidents in other ways right we can
have a fast track
model of decision making that empowers
presidents to make the government more
effective and takes advantage of that
aspect of what presidents have to offer
but then we can also say
insulate the department of justice
and the intelligence agencies from
direct presidential control
by various means trump came very close
to using those powerful agencies in very
very dangerous ways
um we can take steps to drastically
limit
the number of presidential appointees
we can eliminate through constitutional
amendment the pardon power there's never
any justification for that thing
um we can pass legislation that
does away with conflicts of interest
by presidents the laws we have now are
travesty
we can pass legislation that really
restricts
the president's ability to use national
emergency
to take unilateral actions and so on
so we can constrain presidents and
protect ourselves
but at the same time we can empower
presidents
in the legislative process to make the
legislative process which is
a travesty work better so that's the
logic
of that um
just the thing about legacy i i think
presidents are obviously motivated by
legacy they all want to be great they
think about it all the time
and this drives them to want to do good
things for the country
that's a very good thing and this
article about
you know that what gene was saying about
jimmy carter just doesn't
ring true i mean jimmy carter did
actually a lot of good things for this
country
um but he was burdened by a
terrible economy one of the worst
ever in this country you know with huge
unemployment
and through the roof inflation and then
the iranians
took our hostages okay it was he was
done
right and that was part of his legacy
too so it's not as though he didn't
accomplish things
and it's also not that he wasn't trying
because he was
and the important thing is that all
presidents want to try
hard to achieve important things for the
country
and that makes them different from
congress because they're thinking about
cotton and soybeans and they're not
thinking about the kinds of things that
presents are thinking about
perfect timing uh five minutes uh and
now
uh uh five minutes of linguini from
youtube
well i think in the uh
the linguine storm uh professor mo
uh completely missed my point about
jimmy carter or
uh couldn't believe that i wasn't being
sarcastic
in fact jimmy carter was a problem
solver
i think he did great things
in deregulating the transport sector
i think he i think ronald reagan
gets a good bit of the credit
uh for some of the deregulation
that happened under uh jimmy carter
i do think that it would be uh
without uh the wave of reform
that he initially initiated without the
problem
that he very much helped solve
i think that uh you know i think it
would be
the few parts of american society that
that worked well
in this pandemic including uh
fast shipping of various goods would not
have been possible so i was not
joking about carter the man solved
a couple of problems uh and gets
no uh appreciation from
the people who fill out presidential
scorecards
for it uh if you look at
uh the presidential scorecards you will
find
that in the bottom 10 there are no war
presidents the top
10 are larded with them uh
and uh in no way would
uh it's absolutely true that that
presidents care about their legacies
but what uh the uh people who are
filling out their report cards are
telling them
is that being an imperial president who
makes a lot of noise breaks things
uh and does uh
does big things uh is certainly much
more in problem
more more important than the slow boring
of hard boards and solving
genuine national problems that that's my
point it's a bit of a romanticized
uh view of how presidents are motivated
uh
bill clinton used to complain to dick
morris about how hard it was being
president
when we didn't have a an enemy to fight
he used to say i
enjoy i envy jfk uh
you know having an enemy that you can
get people to do what
do things when they're not threatened uh
is harder
um i don't know what else i have i
i think uh the the proposal
uh would make some things worse a few
minor things better
and uh mostly exacerbate the very
problems that howl and mo
uh identify all right okay you took uh
uh just less than three minutes of your
time gene
and uh you know that can't be uh gotten
back that's lost forever
uh we now turn to
uh the q a portion of the evening
and uh we give an opportunity to uh
to gene healy to ask a question of terry
mo
terry mo the opportunity to ask a
question of gene hilly
gene first of all do you want to
exercise that option at this moment
you can exercise it later if you want uh
one of the intriguing things i
i thought about the book and one of the
things that made me uh
think about the proposal a little more
um is i do think it's true that
uh gridlock while it's not an argument
for more presidential power it's
certainly uh drives
presidents uh to strike out on their own
i think that's exactly what happened uh
with the obama
uh directives uh you know implementing
large parts of
the dream act but under this proposal
don't you give everyone two bites at the
apple for example like
uh so if a president uh the president
can go
uh the fast track route he he can put a
legislative proposal
on the table and if it uh
you know if it passes good uh we're all
united behind it
uh if it fails though he's in a worse
position for unilateral action
uh because now he is uh in the uh for
the
executive power law geeks he's in he's
not no longer in the jackson zone of
twilight he's
congress has considered this voted it
down
so he's taken the ability to do it
unilaterally under current
doctrine off the table why wouldn't the
president just
so if if joe biden decides that he
agrees with the
elizabeth warren's uh idea that he can
just forgive
up to fifty thousand dollars in student
loan debt
uh per person he would only put that on
the table right if he
if he thought he was going to win the
vote right otherwise he would just do it
unilaterally
and there would be no argument uh his
argument would be just as good as it was
before uh this amendment passed
so what doesn't this just add more
gamesmanship
uh to and more diffusion of
responsibility
uh to an already diffuse and frustrating
process
there's always going to be gamesmanship
right you know that
and i think presidents are going to have
to figure out what their options are
and uh uh make their moves accordingly
so uh they're going to do the best they
can to get
proposals through congress by
mobilizing support as best they can
within congress
because legislation is better than an
executive order
it's permanent right and they would
rather do that
than issue an executive order right i
think you're right
they don't want to initiate legislation
have cog
and then have congress voted down right
but they're not stupid right so they can
look ahead they can count noses
and uh they just have to figure out what
they're going to go with and what
they're not going to go with
but fast track gives them legislative
options
that they don't have now it gives them
opportunities
to make public policy by
passing legislation and i think
one of the things that has really um
made our democracy so difficult
um over the past number of decades
is that the legislative process doesn't
work
and presidents can't rely on it and so
they have to issue these executive
orders but you know there's a
pale reflection of of real legislation
you know
it's not optimal for the system as a
whole we don't want that we want
legislation
but legislation can't happen most of the
time
right so what i would do is just turn
this back and say look man if you don't
have fast tracks
what do you have just the system as it
exists
then what are you happy with that all
right look look
uh i don't i don't have a
uh a five-point plan to solve executive
uh to solve uh to deliver effective
government
in the areas where i think effective
government is needed
um i don't have to to uh
be able to conclude that your plan
doesn't really do it
uh i think uh look i agree that uh i
think president should
get a up or down vote on uh
all judicial nominations certainly all
executive branch nominations
um i think we we're going to get closer
to that
um i don't know why i should conclude
from that that uh
the president should get to write his
own war authorizations and ram them
through
uh congress uh that can either rubber
stamp them or send them back
uh in a crisis atmosphere uh
i don't i don't see that as making uh
any huge improvements on on what we've
got now
i also furthermore don't see um
many of the large 21st century
initiatives where congress and the
president moved in lockstep
and that have been disasters i don't
really see that they've been uh
maybe obamacare might be uh
you know you may have a point there but
most of them i don't i don't see it as
congressional parochialism
uh screwing up the president's uh
public spirited vision uh
i think uh people got together and and
did stupid things
in a big way and i'm not sure i want to
grease the tracks for more of that to
happen
um i have a a question uh for
you uh terry uh
gene healy said that that the fast track
might be
better in minor ways do you see how
uh on your side do you see how fast
track
authority may be worse in minor ways and
uh and if so could you address the minor
ways in which it
might make matters worse or do you see
no potential
to make matters worse in any way take it
away terry do you have an answer to that
question
yeah yeah my answer is no i i don't see
any ways in in which
fast track would be worse than what we
have now what we have now
is a process that simply doesn't work
gene healy then on your side you said it
could be better in minor ways
so why don't you speak on behalf of it
in minor ways
uh at least for a minute or two in what
way might it be better
yeah sure uh i will say that i i led
before the linguine onslaught with a big
example
in the 2001 aumf and the original bush
administration language in which it
could have been
worse in a major way um but no as i said
i think
uh uh you know i think merrick garland
should have gotten an up or down vote i
don't think uh
uh he i don't care which party's doing
it i think the
the president when he's trying to staff
an administration
should get an up or down vote and i also
think terry is right
um you know years ago i probably would
have said all gridlock is good
uh but i i think terry is right that uh
that it incentivizes uh uh
presidents who have there's a lot of
play in the joints a lot of unilateral
power they can
they can claim there's a lot of
flexibility in statutes because
because congress writes them so broadly
that uh
it doesn't end with gridlock so i i
think uh
barack obama was uh reluctantly
driven into making immigration policy
with the stroke of a pen
which is not ideal and i think that uh
joe biden will be under similar
pressures uh
in a 50 50
senate so i do think something that uh
you know i i don't think it's the case
that gridlock is always good and i think
that uh there is a case to be made that
uh something along the lines of
uh what tara what moe and howell propose
uh some elements of it uh
would cut down on that incentive uh
for the president to strike out it on
his own and just make law by executive
fiat
i don't think it would solve most of the
problems however you want to comment on
that terry or should we get the next
question yeah
well i i do think that we need to
be comparing
these discussions about
possible reforms with the status quo
the status quo is a complete
institutional
mess and we are in a society
that is filled with very very
debilitating consequential problems
that are burying people and are making
people
really angry and really disaffected
from our country and from our democracy
and while people
sit here twiddling their some their
thumbs
and and sort of glorifying
our constitutional system and glorifying
congress as though gee
you know if congress could just get it
together you know and if they could just
act in a bipartisan way
we'd be able to fix these things and all
of that is wrong
you know it's the whole institutional
system that doesn't
work and meantime we're going down
this is a very serious crisis of
democracy that we're in
right now even though trump is out of
office it was worse when trump was in
office if he had won a second term
i have little doubt we would have gone
down now would you want him to have the
fast track amendment if you'd want a
second term
i think in general um
we should have fast track just like i
think in general there should be no
filibuster
no i think we need to take this system
which has so
many obstacles to action
and get rid of most of those obstacles
and have a much more majoritarian
democratic system
so that elections matter
right and so this is not a republican or
democratic thing
sort of ingenious uh thought on the part
of a
person in the chat room uh implying that
maybe this whole idea could be
neutralized
which reads couldn't congress simply
vote down
the president's fast-track bill and then
propose their own version
to the normal legislative process well
why wouldn't that blunt
the worst of gene healy's concerns about
increased
presidential power or actually of course
on terry moe's side if if congress did
that as a matter of course
every time the president comes up with a
fast-track bill they just
vote it down and write their own if
they're uh depending on who's in charge
wouldn't that sort of blunt terry's idea
to begin with but
gene hillary do you want to address that
particular idea that scenario and then
i'll give it to terry
yeah that's another thing that uh it's a
good question it's another thing that
it occurred to me as i was reading the
book uh
i you know i i went back and forth
between
would this be a disaster would it not
matter at all and i think i came
at it as uh it would matter in certain
circumstances particularly under
uh periods of unified government uh
particularly during crisis uh you know
post pearl harbor post 911 moments i
think it'd be especially dangerous
but yeah there's uh uh so i in an
earlier question i thought
i suggested that the president can have
his choice
as to uh if i think i can win the vote
if they got the right whip count
uh then i can do this legislatively
and it'll have more staying power
certainly obama would have preferred
to do that with immigration reform um
but on the flip side yeah uh as the
questor
points out um you know congress
if it's not a crisis situation might be
able to uh
if they're not lockstep with the
president they're not co-partisans it's
divided government
uh put in all their parochial uh sausage
pieces that they wanted anyway uh
you know by just voting down the
president's bill and
uh you know passing their own bill
i i think uh you know i i i think that's
a possibility for sure
uh do you want to be jerry as an answer
to that terry mode you want to address
that question and
uh gene hilly's answer
look um in the limits
it's feasible that congress could just
vote no right like every time the
president proposes something congress
could vote no
and then congress could uh go back uh
and uh devise its own legislation
right uh instead uh which the president
could of course veto
right so that could happen but i think
um the immigration
examples i just gave are good ones
right so here you have these incendiary
issues
and nonetheless they were able to come
up with these packages
that had enough votes to pass in both
the house
and the senate thanks to votes by
democrats and
republicans but the leadership
wouldn't allow them to pass so they died
two of them on filibusters in the senate
one of them because john boehner
wouldn't even let people vote on him
in the house if you took away that
agenda control
we would had immigration
a new immigration law right and
that kind of thing can happen a lot and
anybody
in political science who studies agenda
control
will tell you that the agenda controller
has a great deal of control in
crafting proposals that will win
support from a legislative body
now that doesn't mean that they're
always going to be successful
but the agenda control is in a real
position of power
because they're able to manipulate the
elements
of the proposal taking into account
what kind of support they can get from
different alternatives
so they can come up with one with
sufficient support to pass
right so this idea oh hey congress could
just vote no all the time
okay that's not what you would expect
based on hundreds of studies that have
been
based on exactly this kind of situation
cherry mo
i'm getting a number of questions and
concerns
about an issue that gene healy did raise
having to do with war powers
of the presidency and
a few of them have picked up on gene
healy's concern
that had there been fast track no one a
very broad language
that the bush administration wanted to
apply could have been voted
by congress and there might have been
hell to pay arguably
are you uh concerned uh more broadly
in any way about the war powers of the
presidency
now do you see any way in which fast
track
might worsen that situation
uh is there anything that you want to
say addressing that concern
well two things uh one
in my view fast track can be applied to
some issues and not others
right i mean in the limit they could be
applied to all issues
that doesn't have to be the case
secondly
um presidents are
almost unconstrained in exercising war
powers
right i mean i don't like that but i
think i think that they are
uh highly unconstrained and
uh george bush was you know in
uh starting those wars in afghanistan
and in iraq you know and they go through
the motions
of you know consulting and taking votes
and stuff like that
but basically the president is the man
you know and that's that's what um
the theory the unitary executive is all
about
and that's why the office of legal
counsel is staffed by these people who
believe in the theory
of the unitary executive because they
come up with legal justifications for
why the president can do whatever he
wants to do
um so in my view it's important for
those kinds of things
to change and so for me this is not
really a fast track
issue so much as it is an issue of
the president's unilateral powers in
foreign affairs and national security
because i think they go well beyond
[Music]
what is good for a democracy a
well-functioning democracy
yeah well the question also picked up on
the very point about legacy which
which was gene hilly's point that that
president seemed to be ranked high
if they fought wars and but then you're
saying that
you share that concern and you're saying
then that
you would do something about it is there
something that you would do about it
that you'd like to put forward
you know i i this brings up
constitutional issues that
haven't been resolved right like the war
powers act
was i think a good idea um but
it's also an idea that every president
has declared unconstitutional
and it's never been resolved by the
supreme court
right so this was an attempt to rein in
presidents and i think i think congress
needs to get
more serious about reigning presidents
in when it comes to going to war
it's like they just have to say look
we've had it you know and we need to
take steps that will actually constrain
presidents when it comes to war-making
powers
so then you run into the supreme court
right because it's unclear where the
supreme court will stand on this he's
the commander-in-chief
um and all the rest do you uh
again uh to flag you further only
because of getting a lot of questions
do you then perceive that if
uh your amendment were passed you know
next week
that it could in this vacuum that you
speak of
uh worsen uh the uh the already as you
indicate
uh sorry situation with respect to
presidents
bringing us to war would it worsen it in
any way
do you have that concern well in
principle
it it could but um really
again what's happening is you're
streamlining the process
uh so that the president has to take a
proposal
to the senate and to the house and the
members of the senate and the house
have to vote but he doesn't have to
in war okay well all right about that
we're talking about fast track here
right but uh
okay terry you finished a response for
the moment i was gonna give you ample
opportunity to address
oh sorry that's okay gene terry if you
finish your remarks
for the moment yeah i'll just try to
clear this up a little bit
um because there are
times when presidents go to congress to
get authorization right for the things
that they're going to do or that they
have already started doing
right um and then fast track
still requires that the senate has to
vote yes
and the house has to vote yes you know
so those are good things you know and
their potential constraints on
on what presidents can do but as gene
said
presidents are often doing these things
unilateral they just do them
right and that's the problem
uh that we all face in having a
presidency
that would seem to be too powerful
and too unilateral when it comes to war
making
when you look back and see all the
trouble this nation has gotten into
because of that and uh then taking it to
eugene healy i guess the narrowly
focused question
that you could respond to or speak more
broadly about it is do you see a way in
which
this enhanced fast-track authority could
worsen
the situation with respect to the
president's exercise of war powers
absolutely absolutely uh well uh
most presidents what is true that the
presidents have uh
a largely free hand in military affairs
a de facto if not
you know by any constitutional metric
uh but they would in general since occur
since
korea they've preferred to get congress
on board if they're going to
do a large land invasion of a country
like iraq
uh so that's why or afghanistan it's
what you see
george w bush going for those uh
going for congressional authorization of
some sort in those kinds of
situations that's basically been the war
powers dynamic
since korea um i think the fast track
proposal
gives them in a crisis atmosphere like
something like september 11th the
ability to put their preferred language
in front of congress immediately after
the fact
rubber stamp it or say no to this injury
that's been dealt us
and i think they're in a better position
uh i think they
i think fast track does nothing to
uh to change the the basic dynamic that
we've had since korea
um and uh possibly gives them another
tool
that in crisis situations could be very
dangerous but they're still going to
have the choice
as they would with legislation of uh how
do they feel about it do i want to use
my unilateral it does nothing about
their unilateral powers
uh how do i feel about it do i want to
use my unilateral military powers that
i'm claiming
or get congress uh
to buy in and uh so i i think it does
little to get rid of the problem uh and
uh you know potentially a lot to make it
worse
that concludes the q a portion of the
evening
we now go to the summations you at least
are going to be given a full
seven and a half minutes uh to summarize
and uh you are the affirmative terry so
you go first
uh take it away terry just to sum up a
few things i didn't write out
a formal statement uh completely
but here are a few basic points that i
just want to drive home
we have a government that doesn't work
now and congress is at the heart of the
dysfunction
it has two houses it has 535 members
they're tied to different states and
districts
and as an institution it's just filled
with veto points and collective action
problems that make any sort of action
very difficult
and even when it can act it cobbles
together bills that are patchwork
creations that are filled with special
interest divisions and
designed to get enough votes to pass not
to provide coherent
well-justified policies that are finely
tuned to actually
solve the nation's problems effectively
this is just unacceptable
it really is the problems that we're
facing
as a modern nation get more and more
complicated and more and more
debilitating
you know and if we can't solve these
problems
they're going to tear this society apart
and they're also going to convince
people
that this government doesn't deserve to
be supported
so because of our government
effectiveness these problems are
destroying
our quality of life and this same
ineffectiveness is also dangerous for
our democracy because a government that
can't meet the needs of its people
gives rise to alienation and anger to
populism
and to a rejection of democracy itself
it's already happening it's been
happening
throughout the trump years that's what
gave rise to the trump presidency
and it threatens to bring our down our
democracy
trump threatened to bring down our
democracy
we need to do something fast track is
one way of getting to the heart of the
matter
and trying to make our government work
it's a very conservative reform
you know it's small it's well tested for
over four decades
five minutes done and it leaves the rest
of the government
fully intact it deserves our support i
think
so um
so gene has lobbed
a number of different points up there
and um to me they don't add up to
a coherent hole a coherent counter
argument you know he knows he doesn't
like
uh fast track but there's not a coherent
persuasive argument
why um so
it's a little hard to just pick out
specific things
and argue against them um
so let me try to pick out
just a few um
you know so so jimmy carter again
you know jimmy carter desperately wanted
a strong legacy one to be regarded as a
great president like everybody else
um and what gene points out is that well
he did
really important things but he didn't
get credit for them
you know and that's true
but so what you know what's important
here
is we want to know what motivates
presidents
and especially we want to know what
motivates them by comparison to what
motivates members of congress
members of congress are not sitting
around thinking how they can come up
with
solutions to the nation's problems and
how to make them the most effective
possible that's not the way members of
congress work
you know they're thinking about soybeans
or something small
something local something parochial
something that will get them reelected
presidents have to be thinking big about
these things
that's the big difference between
presidents and members of congress and
that's why we need president so much
in the legislative process to make the
legislative process
work right and like with carter
okay he did some good things but in the
end
the economy was horrible the iranians
took our hostages
and that's what mainly determined his
legacy those things took him down
because they were part of his legacy
there were good parts and there were bad
parts and the bad parts dragged him down
think about lyndon johnson gee what he
accomplished you know the civil rights
act the voting rights act the elementary
and secondary education act
uh medicare medicaid unbelievable you
know the
the the great society program but
he also got us into vietnam okay what's
his legacy
well at the end of the day people said
getting us into vietnam was so bad
that johnson has a bad legacy even
though his domestic legacy probably went
way beyond fdrs
right so legacy's not a simple thing
presidents are striving for it right it
just about killed lyndon johnson
that he got tainted by this vietnam war
right but the important thing from our
standpoint
is that legacy drives presidents and
legacy gives us a way to understand why
presidents do what they do it gives us a
way
to help predict their decisions
and to know that presidents will behave
differently from legislators
and if we want to have an effective
government we're much better off
in the hands of presidents than we are
in the hands of 535 legislators
right who will put together bills that
will not solve social problems
presidents want to solve social problems
we're in better hands
with them and so that's why
this simple shift to fast track is this
is a reasonable way of trying to move us
along this path
toward a more effective government while
leaving the whole rest of the government
the same right so that's that's the
basic argument
and you can pick away at it and you know
complain about one aspect or another but
i think
what it often comes down to is yeah
well what are the ideas on the other
side you're going to leave everything
the way it is good luck with that
what are the other ideas for making the
government more effective let's hear
them
right i think fast track is an excellent
idea
it's simple it's easy to do and it works
thank you terry
uh gene healy your summation seven and a
half minutes
uh take it away gene healy with the
apologies to yes minister
terry said we need to do something maybe
we do
fast track is something but it shouldn't
be done
it doesn't respond to any of the
problems most of the problems that that
he's identified
um he uh
well let's look at uh i thought we would
have gotten to this but i guess we
didn't but uh
as i was preparing for this uh i thought
about uh
kovit i mean it's certainly right
government is ineffective
uh the uh the last year or so was
a stress test for american
the the federal government and uh it
certainly didn't perform well
uh you know we've got a higher death
rate than
most of europe it's amazing to me that
we're vaccinating faster than most of
europe
given how uh horrible and inefficient
the vaccination process
looks like uh from from the ground level
but how many of our problems with kovid
were due to
uh veto points impeding bold legislative
action how many of our problems
uh in the big ticket items that have
passed in the 21st century
the uh you know iraq and afghanistan war
authorizations
the bank bailouts and on and on were
due to congressional the problems stem
from congressional parochialism and uh
log rolling uh you know terry doesn't
like linguini
he does certainly doesn't like watching
sausage being made
but uh in throughout the course of this
century
uh when congress has done big things it
doesn't seem to me
that what spoiled them was congressional
parochialism and during the immediate
crisis
there are a lot of veto points there are
a lot of veto players they're not the
ones that
uh terry talks about or that uh his
proposal would do anything about
a lot of them in this current crisis
were the in the executive branch
the fda in the cdc holding up early
testing
the cdc holding up testing in february
of last year
uh you know when tesla had already been
developed in who in germany
not allowing it to be approved because
the cdc wanted their own test
uh you know we lost two months in the
pandemic there
uh we lost uh at least a couple of
months
uh in vaccine approval with the uh
with the fda dragging its feet and not
working weekends and not
treating this like an emergency
situation even though they
eventually gave emergency authorization
to a few of the vaccines
there are a lot of veto players a lot of
detail points
uh that contribute to making
american government woefully ineffective
uh and may even add to the general
ambience that
makes people angry and uh
you know willing to be anti-system
players
but most of them as far as i can tell
are not in congress i uh
i hold no particular brief from congress
other than a constitutional one
but you know yeah okay
i i i you know i don't want to
uh be seen as carrying water for
congress other than it's a
constitutional role
uh there was a uh some years back a
bunch of
uh smart ass pollsters did a poll that
i quite liked where they uh they
asked people uh to rank congress against
uh
various unpleasant things like uh i
think it was
lice colonoscopies and nickelback
and uh all of these unpleasant things
beat congress um
you know congress uh deserves uh in many
ways the lack of respect
that it gets but it does not seem to me
other than
fairly indirectly uh it has been
respond the lack of fast track authority
and uh
the filibuster and uh the the
the power of the house and senate
leadership has been what has made this
pandemic such a disaster for americans
uh you know it's uh executive branch
players
in uh the administrative state and in
some cases in the state house governor's
office
um and so
while i think uh government should be
more effective i would like government
to be more effective in the things that
it should
legitimately be doing i see nothing
that uh in particular that fast track
would do
to end this general sense of government
ineffectiveness
and i see at least a few things it could
do
to uh you know grease the the wheels for
uh
for more disasters along the lines that
we had after 9 11 and during
the financial crisis and uh
well i guess i i guess i'll leave it
there
uh you mr speaker i yield back the
balance of my time
all right thank you gene healy uh and
that concludes
our debate thank you terry thank you
gene looks like we got the voting
results
in summary it was pretty close again
whoever wins
is so to quote unquote wins and gets the
tootsie roll
is the one who moves the needle in his
favor the yes vote
initially uh on behalf of the resolution
defended by terry mo was 4.55 percent
and terry you gained nine percentage
points you moved up to thirteen
point six percent a gain of nine
percentage points
is the number to beat uh uh gene healy's
uh defending the no side went from 63.6
to 77.2 picking up 13.6 points
so the 13.6 exceeds the nine
that you gained uh gene you're looking
perplexed that
you you've got 13 percentage points gain
and
uh and terry got a nine percentage point
gain
so you had a four percentage point
margin a victory
gene healy you get the tootsie roll
congratulations to terry congratulations
to gene thank you very much for a superb
debate and we hope
to see you all soon at the soul forum
good night